[Music]
and greetings to all of you, our friends
of this ministry and our wonderful SumTV
family. This is I'd like to know. I'm CA
Murray. To my left, our general manager
of SumTV Latino, Pastor David Salazar.
>> Thank you, pastor, for allowing me to be
with you here today. And to my right,
the president and founder of this
ministry, Pastor Steven Boore. Pastor,
good to have you here.
>> It's a pleasure.
>> We are just back from a wonderful
general conference session. Very
interesting session. We want to thank
those of you who came by uh to greet us
and to meet us, to shake hands with us,
and those of you who added to our
program by asking your questions on air,
and hopefully you are enjoying your gift
now. We want you to wear it proud
proudly and to uh to keep the the fire
burning as it were. Keep the flag flying
high. Thank you for being part of our
experience and of our production. Our
production people one and all want to
thank you for being part of our
broadcast. Now this is the Bible
question and answer program. We want you
to be part of the program and you can do
so by writing your questions in. Sad
sadly you cannot come now. You have to
write your questions in to TV at sums
summ as in marytv.org
that is tvsumtv.org
and we will get to your questions. We
are happy to answer your questions. We
ask you to let let us know your name and
where they are your questions are coming
from. If you don't, we will answer them
just the same. But putting uh an address
or a country or a state or a city lets
us kind of know what our footprint is
and uh where we are being a blessing. So
if you would do that for us, we will
thank you in advance. I'm going to ask
Pastor Board to ask God's blessing on
this particular sitting and then we will
launch out uh in today's program.
>> Let's pray. My father in heaven, we come
before you with humility of heart,
>> but at the same time pleading for wisdom
to answer these questions in harmony
with your holy word. We ask that you
will bless this program, that you will
bless those who are watching this
program, that it might be a spiritual
benefit for their life, for their daily
walk with the Lord. Be with us. Give us
clarity of thought. Give us clear words
to speak. We pray in Jesus name. Amen.
Amen. Amen.
>> Our first question comes to us from
Gabriel
in Zimbabwe. Uh Pastor Salazar, would
you read 2 Kings chapter 13
verses 20 and 21 to sort of give us the
context for this particular question?
>> Absolutely. 2 Kings chapter 13 20 and
21. It says there, "Then Elisha died,
and they buried him, and the raiding
bands from Moab invaded the land in the
spring of the year. So it was as they
were burying a man that suddenly they
spied a band of raiders, and they put
the man in the tomb of Elisha." And when
the man was let down and touched the
bones of Elisha, he revived and stood on
his feet.
>> Amen. And amen.
Um, pastor, you want to sort of lead out
this one because I've got some stuff,
but I want to put my eyes on the heels
of what of what you say because you have
this way of digesting things and taking
it down to its least common denominator
very very succinctly. So, go ahead and
do so. Well, I think we need to look at
this um in relationship with the
ministry of Elijah.
>> In the Bible, Elijah is always the
precursor to the coming of the Messiah.
>> You know, in the Old Testament, Elijah
prepares the way for Elisha.
>> And in the New Testament, John the
Baptist prepares the way for uh Jesus.
>> Yeah. And in the end time, the remnant
church prepares the way for the second
coming of Christ. So we are to look at
Elisha as a type of Christ.
>> In fact, Elisha performed many more
miracles than Elijah did.
>> You know, I mentioned some of them. The
parting of the Jordan, the uh purifying
of the waters of Jericho. Yes.
>> Uh the protection of the prophet from
the shebears. Uh the widow's
multiplication of the oil, this
resurrection of the son of the
Schumanite. uh uh the par uh the
purification of the poison soup,
>> multiplied loaves, interestingly enough,
healed non
>> uh afflicted Gahhesi with leprosy uh and
did the miracle of the floating axe.
These are some of them. There were about
18 of them.
>> Uh and so uh he is a type of Christ.
>> I think we need to understand that
>> uh when we read these particular verses
and I'll let you guys follow up on that.
Okay,
>> thank you pastor. This is so interesting
the story of Elisha. He actually died um
with a illness and and kind of
painfully. Nevertheless, he never gave
his faith trust in the Lord. He loved
the Lord and he encouraged the king of
Israel to trust and follow the Lord. So
he was a faithful example as you
mentioned a type of Jesus in many ways
and he had to take upon himself you
know, or he received an illness that he
didn't deserve. You know, that man was a
faithful man to God, but why did the
Lord allow him to have this illness and
consequently die? Again, to to me, it
sort of represents a life of someone who
has to burn bear the burdens and remain
faithful to the Lord. And as he died, as
you well mentioned, he was put in the
tomb. And I think that by understanding
what you were saying pastor we can
understand this interesting concept in
the tomb of Christ angels were appointed
to guard the tomb of go Christ when he
was on the grave and those angels were
there to to take care of Christ's body
until he was given the power to or to
resurrect. Elijah Elisha did not did not
of course did not have that experience.
He was not resurrected but angels were
appointed to him to to guard even his
his sleeping or his you know his dead or
his the dead experience. And so as he's
there when they put the men when they
lowered the men it was not the bones of
Elisha that have the power to give back
life. It was not the bones of Elisha
that had any miracle power in
themselves. They're not divine. They're
just bones. But because angels were
appointed to guard the tomb of a
faithful prophet of God in a concept to
to to teach and I believe that was the
lesson of to me that's the one of the
lessons I can grab from this the you
know the power of a holy man a man of
God the influence is is is something
that God cares for and that man who was
resurrected by touching this sacred or
dwelling place of rest was an evidence
that the spirit of God had been with
Elijah, had been with God with I mean
with him and he was still guarded by
God's angels. So I I think it was a
testimony of the office the prophet
prophetic gift that he had and the
importance that people had to res to to
to to um to accept to heed to the
instructions of Elisha.
>> Well said. I I have a message on this
that I call double trouble. Once um
Elisha received the double portion of
the Holy Spirit.
>> Um Elan says he never lost his faith in
God. Never. Never went back. Always
forward. Anytime something opposed him,
he always pressed forward in faith. In
fact, he was such a holy man. I'm glad
you you recounted that list of miracles.
People actually began to think of him a
little higher than than they ought to.
not his fault, but a person pulls out
that many miracles, you kind of think of
him in lofty terms. So, he was afflicted
with a a long
disease before he died. Uh suffered
quite a while. But even during that
disease, he never questioned the Lord.
He never lost his faith in God. Now,
with this great holy man, let's look at
his obituary. His obituary is in 2 Kings
13:14.
One line, one verse. Elisha became sick
with the illness of which he would die.
Period. That's it. That's it.
>> Great life. List of miracles that you
recounted, Pastor Bor, he gets one line
in his obituary. He he he got sick and
he died. Now, of course, there are many
messages that can be drawn from that
because the works that you do don't
commend to you uh any sort of long life
or anything. Great is your reward in
heaven. So, he got sick and he died. But
in one last little
uh miracle, the Lord allowed a a a a a
dead man to be raised. So Elijah holds
the titular distinction of being the
first, the last, the only person who
raised somebody from the dead while he
was alive and raised somebody from the
dead when he himself was dead. And of
course, we know that any act of raising
from the dead is is God. But God used
that that mechanism. It it says a number
of things to me that we are are called
to be faithful. Let the Lord take care
of the long-term consequences. Our job
is to be faithful and to serve him. And
just because you are faithful doesn't
mean you get a free pass, pastor, on
life. You still got to serve. You still
got to suffer sometimes. You still got
to hold on to the hands of Jesus. And he
did so. So we don't have to feel bad
about Elijah and his long sickness
because his reward is sealed uh in the
kingdom. We need to be absolutely
certain that we recognize that there was
no magic in the bones of Elijah.
>> Precisely.
>> The focus has to be on the power of God
>> to to do this miracle.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh through through the ministry of the
angels like you were mentioning, pastor.
>> Um we we need to make sure that we don't
become superstitious,
>> right? Yes.
>> And think that there was some virtue in
the bones. The virtue is in the Lord.
And of course, if we understand that
Elisha is a type of Christ,
>> Yes.
>> then uh this is a type of those who are
in Christ that will resurrect at the end
of the age.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah. You know, it's it's just and and
we'll get off this in just a second just
to think about the the scenario. You've
got the attacking Moabites. Uh you've
got this funeral possession. They're
they're they're interrupting a funeral
possession and they floor swords
flashing and people screaming and all
this kind of stuff. We got this body.
What do we do with this body? throw it
in a hole and and you know all a sudden
the body jumps up and you running like
everybody else. It must have been an
incredible thing to see.
>> So, so it's just that's how my mind
works. So, for forgive me, but uh God is
a good God. All righty, we are going to
question um 61 now.
>> Yes.
>> From Braden from Washington State, I
have a question concerning the
appearances of the Godhead in scripture.
We see several times when God comes down
to meet with man in quote disguise. Some
examples the burning bush, the commander
who spoke to Joshua, one of the three
men that came to Abraham
uh of which two were angels that
continued with Abraham to Sodom, the man
who fought Jacob in the river, etc. How
many of these appearances of God do we
ascribe to God the Father versus
pre-incarnate Christ versus Holy Spirit?
Who was it on the mountain with Moses?
Who was the flaming tornado
uh during the Exodus? There are many
more examples that I can list. I know
that we say God uh the father sits on
the throne in heaven. So, does this mean
all appearances of God in the Old
Testament are God the Son pre-incarnate
or are there exceptions where uh God the
Father himself came down?
Okay. The Ellen White makes it very
clear that both the father and the son
descended to Mount Si when the law was
given. But that's the only clear
instance that I find
>> in the Bible where God the father
actually comes down. Uh the father did
not come down at the incarnation of
Christ. The angels took care of that.
>> Yes.
>> Um the angels will come with Christ at
the second coming sent by the father.
>> So uh you know there's there's no
evidence that the father uh gets off of
his throne and comes down to the earth.
Now having said that um the instances
that um Braden presents here are clearly
a reference to Christ.
>> Amen.
>> You know like like Joshua for example
the experience of Joshua chapter 5.
>> Yes.
>> U the burning bush.
>> You know clearly the the person in the
burning bush is Christ.
>> Because later on you know Jesus says
before Abraham was I am. the Jews
understood him that he was saying that
he was the person in the burning bush
>> and you could tell they understood him
because they tried to kill him right
then.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. That's the response.
>> So the bottom line is that we usually
think that Christ's role in the plan of
salvation is when he became incarnate.
>> Mhm.
>> But all throughout the Old Testament,
Christ is the father's emissary to this
earth to prepare the way through many
events for his coming. uh as the word
incarnate.
>> Furthermore, in um first John I mean in
John chapter one just John the gospel of
John chapter 1 verse 18 he declares no
one has seen God speaking of the father
at any time the only begotten son who is
in the bosom of the father he declared
him. So
there is no ev evidence that no one ever
seen God the father but Jesus has been
the one that was revealing to the father
or revealing the father through his
interaction as you said with mankind. It
was Jesus in all the instances that we
see in the Bible, you know, he's called
the angel of God, Michael. Uh, and so,
you know, captain of the hosts and so he
is though he is the one that has in in
most of the times being or all the times
that we can see in the Bible interaction
between anyone of the godhead is Jesus
and his servants. Uh, that's really what
the Bible declares, not not the father.
And like I said, you know, John says
clearly that no one has ever seen the
father
>> and he's the one who struggled
>> with Jacob.
>> Correct.
>> You know, because
Jacob named that place pineal,
>> which means the face of God seen God
faith face to face and I've survived to
to tell the story, right?
>> Uh so in all of these he's called he's
called Michael like you were mention
mentioning. He's called the angel of the
Lord, the angel of his presence, uh the
commander of the Lord's hosts.
>> Uh there are many names attached to
Christ and each one of those names has
significance.
>> Yes.
>> For example, the name Michael means who
is like God.
>> Like God,
>> it's actually a challenge. And Michael
is always in a struggle with Satan and
Michael always wins.
>> Amen.
>> And when Michael wins, his people win
with him.
>> Right? So, so these are simple
designations
uh for different names for Christ.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I like that. The the
designations deal with the time, the
place, the appearance uh what went on at
that place. So, the name given is has
reference to the event that happened uh
that caused that appearance. And another
important point is that whenever there
is this encounter with uh you know
heavenly being of of the godhead in this
case case Jesus there's always the
attitude of worship and kneeling and
worshiping this you know being which is
one of the godhead angels never true
angels angels of god will never allow a
human being to worship them right
>> they encourage them to hey don't ever do
that I mean
>> yeah I'm a servant with So,
>> and it's interesting that uh in the
burning bush uh God tells Moses, "Take
off the shoes off your feet, your
sandals,
>> for the place you are is holy."
>> Right?
>> And then uh in Joshua chapter 5 where uh
Joshua is about to fight the battle of
Jericho with the armies of Israel. He
meets this person outside the city.
>> Yeah.
>> And he says he has a drawn sword. He
says, "Are you one of us or are one of
them?"
And he says, uh, you know, I'm the
commander of the Lord's host. And then
he says the same thing as the person in
the burning bush.
>> He says, take the shoes off your feet
because the place you are is holy. So
the same person that appeared in the
burning bush is the same person that
appeared to Joshua in the vicinity of
Jericho.
>> And no angel would ever make that
command. So we know we're dealing with a
higher power. Well done, gentlemen. Good
question. Good answer. Thank you so
very, very much. We do not have a Oh, we
do. Ghana uh tea or tema te- a from
Ghana
1 John 3:12 pastor bore would you read
that for us or prepare to read that as I
go into the question
uh well she I
>> it says not as Cain who was of the
wicked one and killed his brother why
did he kill him because his works were
unrighteous and his son's his brother's
works righteous
>> some some Christians try to give a
literary literary meaning.
>> Literal,
>> right?
>> Ah,
>> it means literal.
>> Literal. Yeah.
Meaning as in Cain was a son of the
devil because she had an affair with Eve
or he had an affair with Eve in the
garden. Abel on the other hand had the
nature of Adam because he was really
birthed out of Adam knowing his wife
Eve. How true is this concept?
>> All right. Uh uh it's an question. I
never heard this before, but uh let's if
we just go to the book of Genesis,
chapter
4, we actually have what the Bible
describes as the father of Cain.
Okay. So, this idea of the devil having
an affair with Eve, it's just crazy. But
let's just go to the Bible. Genesis 4
chapter 1. It says, "Now Adam knew Eve
his wife,
>> and she conceived and bore Cain
and said, "I have acquired a man from
the Lord." Cain was the firstborn of the
union of Adam and Eve. That's as simple
as that. There's nothing to it.
>> Okay, next question.
>> Yeah, but you know, but it's true. I
mean, you know, but unfortunately, I
don't know what some people really look
into sometimes the Bible. I guess they
just connect in their minds some ideas.
They they come up with some some
concepts that are contrary to the
scripture and really not well versed.
But, uh, I understand Samson has this
question and he's really uh, you know, I
guess he has this idea u, and it's
because people don't read the scripture.
I think that's really the bottom line
what people some Christians have this
idea and come to this conclusion.
>> Yeah. Well, you know, it's interesting.
And I think that the argument that is
being used is that it says not as Cain
who was of the wicked one.
>> So they say, "Oh, he was literally
physically of the wicked one."
>> But you know that is blown out of the
water by a statement that Jesus made in
John 8.
>> Mhm.
>> John 8:44. There's a group of people
that are opposing Christ.
>> And uh you know there he's talking about
Abraham and so on. And he says to this
group of people, you are of your father,
the devil. Now, was the devil the
literal father of those people?
Absolutely not.
>> They had the same spirit as the devil.
Yes.
>> Because they wanted to kill Christ and
the devil would have liked to have
killed Christ
>> and actually he was instrumental in
leading the Jews to do that.
>> So, uh you know the problem is they
don't compare scripture with scripture.
>> Yes. and they have an agenda and uh they
impose it on scripture.
>> And it's it's it's interesting there is
and this is also this actually helps us
understand even later why the Bible in
Genesis chapter 6 speaks of the sons of
men versus the sons of God.
>> Sons of God daughters of men. Right.
Right. So there is two
>> um types and groups of people. daughters
of of of of men or sons of men and sons
of God, but they're not in any way
linked to a divine origin or or or
mingling between of this of of a seed of
of divine origin has nothing to do with
that. Even though some religions and
some people take that and say, "Oh,
angels of God, you know, had daughters
or something like that or, you know, had
came to to to copulate with with women."
And that is preposterous is really
messed up is a is a completely wrong
concept. But unfortunately through
movies, Hollywood, through ideas,
through myth, Greek mythology, all these
ideas have become kind of embraced by
Christianity and again is not biblical.
>> The bottom line is that Jesus laid this
whole issue to rest when he said that
angels are not do not marry and are not
given in marriage. Right?
>> Uh the the angels
are not able to procreate.
>> God established procreation for a
specific purpose. This earth is
different than any other world that God
created and the beings in that world.
>> In those worlds, there's no procreation.
>> Yes.
>> The purpose of procreation on this earth
was to replace the vacancies that were
left in heaven by Satan and his angels.
And so, uh, Jesus is very clear that the
angels don't procreate. And Satan is an
angel.
>> So, there's no way that Satan could have
had sexual relations with Eve. Mhm.
>> And the product was Cain. Simply
preposterous.
>> In all due deference to Samson, there
are many religions. I' I've heard this
preached and and taught that there was
some sort of cohabitation between angels
and and men. There's more people believe
that than than you would you would
think. But, you know, you've got to let
the Bible be its own interpreter. And
and you you've got to do here a little
there. You don't de develop a doctrinal
premise by one text.
>> You've got to see what the weight of the
Bible uh has on this particular text.
When you gather all the things together,
then you bake your cake. Not one
ingredient here, one ingredient. By the
way, Jewish tradition does teach that
the sons of God before the flood were
angels.
>> Mhm.
>> And the daughters of men were human
women and they produced hybrids, which
were the giants.
>> Yeah.
>> That that that's preposterous. I mean
it's uh it's an interpretation mostly by
by scholars uh contemporary scholars
because of spiritualism become so
prevalent and everything but there's no
basis to that.
>> Yeah this is paganistic views and
influence of the enemy trying to confuse
people and not to know the lord the
bible word of god.
>> So Samson again we thank you well done
good question and uh hopefully we've
answered it to your satisfaction and the
glory of god. So, thank you for uh all
the questions that have come in on this
particular program. So, quickly our time
slips into eternity. Uh we wish you
God's grace and goodness. We wish you
his blessings as you study the word of
God. Study to show thyself approved. A
workman that doesn't need to be ashamed,
right, dividing word of truth. We'll see
you again soon. Bye-bye. God bless.
[Music]
Heat.